foreign
[Music]
s people are so excited about generative
AI right now is that it allows you to
prototype applications really fast
with the right tools you can experiment
with new ideas in minutes instead of
months so let's dive in and check out
generative AI Studio which lets you
quickly explore and customize generative
AI models that you can leverage in your
applications on Google Cloud
you can find generative AI studio and
the vertex AI section of the cloud
console and select the type of content
for your use case
to get started experimenting with large
language models or llms click on new
prompt in the world of generative AI a
prompt is just a fancy name for the
input text that you feed to your model
you can get one of these models to take
on all sorts of different behaviors
based on how you structure your prompt
this Art and Science of figuring out the
best prompt for your use case is called
prompt design and it often involves a
lot of experimentation but that's
regenerative AI studio is here to help
let's start with the freeform prompt
one way to design a prompt is to Simply
tell the model what you want in other
words provide an instruction
for example generate a list of items I
need for a camping trip to Joshua Tree
National Park
we send this text to the model
and you can see that the model outputs a
useful list of items we wouldn't want to
camp without this approach writing a
single command to get the llm to take on
a certain behavior is called zero shot
prompting now llms are particularly good
at identifying and completing patterns
so in addition to writing an instruction
it can be helpful to add some examples
and show the model what you want that's
where few shot prompting comes in in
this approach you provide the model with
a few examples and to make it easier you
can use a structured prompt template
the structured prompt contains a few
different components first we have the
context which instructs how the model
should respond you can specify words the
model can or cannot use topics to focus
on or avoid or a particular response
format and the contacts applies each
time you send a request to the model
so let's say we want to use an llm to
answer questions based on some
background text in this case a passage
describing changes in reinforest
vegetation in the Amazon
we can paste in the background text as
context
and then we add some examples of
questions that could be answered from
this passage like what does lgm stand
for or what did the analysis from the
sediment deposits indicate
we'll need to add in the corresponding
answers to these questions to
demonstrate how we want the model to
respond
then we can test out the prompt we've
designed by sending a new question as
input and there you go you've prototyped
a q a system based on background text in
just a few minutes it's important to
note that adding instructions and a few
examples tends to yield good results but
at the end of the day there's currently
no best way to write a prompt
experimenting with prompts is a core
part of being a generative AI developer
you'll want to try out different
structures and formats and examples and
really just see what works best for your
use case and the specific model you're
working with so if you've designed a
prompt that you think is working pretty
well you can save it and return to it
later
your saved prompt will be visible in the
prompt Gallery which is a curated
collection of sample prompts that show
how generative AI models can work for a
variety of use cases
finally in addition to trying out
different prompts and prompt structures
there are a few model parameters you can
experiment with to try to improve the
quality of responses
first there are different models you can
choose from each model is tuned to
perform well on specific tasks
you can also specify the temperature top
p and top K these parameters all adjust
the randomness of responses by
controlling how the output tokens are
selected when you send a prompt to the
model it produces an array of
probabilities over the words that could
likely come next
and from this array we need some
strategy to decide what to return
a simple strategy might be to select the
most likely word at every time step but
this method can result in uninteresting
and sometimes repetitive answers
on the flip side if we were to randomly
sample over the distribution returned by
the model you might get some unlikely
responses by controlling the degree of
Randomness you can get more unexpected
and some might even say creative
responses
you've now written your first prompt
with vertex generative AI Studio there
are a lot of other features to explore
like Vision capabilities chat and model
tuning for when you want some extra
customization but more on all of that
next time check out the links below to
learn more about generative AI on vertex
and to learn more about large language
models thanks for watching and
definitely let us know in the comments
below what you're building with
generative AI
[Music]